Thank you all for uh, for being
here. Um, it's uh, yeah, I'm, I'm,
I'm glad to be here too. Um, so I'm
going to be talking about translation.
Translation is a huge topic that people
can come out from lots of different
angles.
Um,
I imagine this is quite a multilingual
and transnational kind of audience. Is it,
I mean Google is obviously a
hugely international company. Um,
so translation and communication between
languages I guess is something that is
important in your organization,
in your working lives. Um,
I'm going to try and mainly talk about
things that are different from that. Um,
what I'm going to do is say a
little bit about, uh, you know,
a bit more about who I am
and where I'm coming from.
So my interest in how I got interested
in the field of translation.
Then I'm going to look at various
different instances of practices of moving
between languages,
which couldn't get called translation
because I think one of the things to see
and thinking about translation is that
there are lots of different kinds of
thing that couldn't
get called translation.
So what we're really dealing with
here is an umbrella word with lots of
different,
um,
ways of doing things that are different
and important ways that nevertheless all
get called translation.
Um,
then I'm going to try to think a bit
about the relationship between translation
and languages because if
you've got translation, then
you have to have languages.
But what is the language anyway?
Um,
and how does the practice that we call
or the range of practices that we call
translation relate to the kind of range
of phenomena that we call languages.
Um, and then I'm going to ask how
things might be changing, um, now. Um,
and I hope you'll be able to help me
with that because obviously the internet
and what Google does is a huge part of,
of how the whole landscape
of communication is
changing at the moment. Um,
so what, why is this interesting to
me? So I'm a literary person. Um,
I write novels is Yon said, and I
also write literary historical books.
So when I was a kid I was
interested in just in reading. Um,
and then I did the very typical thing that
happens in the UK, which is so, I mean,
it's not really a monolingual culture,
but there are large stretches
of UK culture, which, you know,
are predominantly monolingual.
So I did the thing that's very typical
for a kid in the UK. He likes reading.
I went to university and I found myself
studying a subject called English, um,
without having really, you know, realize
that that was what was going to happen.
So when I was a teenager, I
liked reading books, you know,
from lots of different places.
And they didn't really matter
to me whether they were
in translation or not. Um,
and I found myself in a university
structure, um, that was set up,
uh, in, I mean, this
happened to be in Cambridge,
but it could have been in many other
universities and institutional structure
that was set up early in the 20th
century when the idea of Englishness and
creating an English national identity
was really important. And so the notion,
the attachment, the idea that what you
should read is kind of English books, uh,
was quite a sort of dominant.
Um,
idea there as it also is in the university
where I teach now, which is awesome.
Um, what I found myself getting interested
in was writers who weren't really very
English at all.
So I found myself getting interested,
particularly in some writers from
the mid 19th century. For instance,
Robert Browning, I don't know if you,
you know any of his poems, but, uh,
he's the right, he very much likes
setting his poems in foreign countries,
especially Italy. Um, and
setting them in the past. Um,
and creating a setup in which you have
to imagine that the person is speaking.
The poem is speaking quite a different
language is speaking, you know,
the sort of Italian,
the Italian spoke in the 16th century
and the other words on the page are
English words.
And so there's a sort of silent implicit
translation that's part of what's going
on in the poem. Um, and indeed,
another thing about what branding
does is that he writes, you know,
like many poets,
many literary writers,
he uses language in strange
and surprising ways. Um,
and part of how he came to do this,
it struck me is that he's very interested
in taking ways of using language from
other languages and trying to bring
them into English. So for instance,
there's a poem from 1855 called an
epistle containing the strange medical
experience of Car Sheesh, the Arab
physician, a branding doesn't know Arabic,
but he's got a sense of
what Arabic, um, is like.
And he tries to write his English
in such a way that it has a kind of
strangeness about it. So for
instance, there'll be lines,
the speaker will say things like,
instead of saying, I arrived at Jericho,
the speaker will say,
my journeyman's were brought to Jericho.
And what I got interested in was,
you know,
and that's quite as a
piece of literary writing.
That's a strange and interesting line,
but it's come to be like
that through translation.
And so what I was noticing increasingly
in the stuff I was reading and getting
interested in was an overlap between
translation and literary creativity.
When you look at a literary texts, you
wanted to do something new in language.
And quite often actually,
you know,
surprisingly often new stylistic things
were being done in language through
either actual translation or sort of
being aware of what another language would
be like. So I had that, but
then I also had this in my mind,
this sort of cliche that there is around
in the culture that translations are
never as good as the original literature
always loses something in translation.
Poetry is what is lost in translation
as the American poet Robert Frost is,
is reported as having is
reported as having said,
I thought it Google of all
places we wouldn't have this
kind of problem with the
Avl, but hey, it's nice
to know. Um, anyway,
uh, yeah, so that was one thing. Then the,
the other thing is that when
I started writing fiction,
so,
um,
I grew up in a completely monolingual
standard English speaking household in
London.
Um,
but my parents were scientists and so
they spoke actually a language that was
quite strange to me.
Lots of scientific words that I didn't
understand when I was a kid and I still
don't really understand.
Um,
and I found that when I
started writing fiction,
I was interested in using kinds of English
that weren't universally compensable.
Um, so Maura, or at least
are a bit peculiar. Um,
so my first novel is in the
voice of an interior designer.
He uses lots of interior design jargon.
Um,
and I was interested in the sort
of distinctiveness of that voice.
And my second novel has got a cause.
My family of doctors,
my second novel has got,
it's very much in the mind of a doctor.
And I was interested in that
special language that doctors know,
that allows them to describe the world
and understand things about people that,
you know, people just be ordinary
English like me, can't do.
So I kind of mucked up on frantically
mugged up and lots of medical terminology
in order to, um, in order
to create this character.
So what I realized I was working
with there was the feeling that, um,
English isn't just a language.
English is a whole range of different
ways of using the language and actually to
move, you know, one
encounters I encounter,
everybody encounters kinds of languages.
The counters, one's own language,
you know, a kind of languages that counts
as English that I don't understand.
And that's an experience
that happens the whole time.
It happens when I'm talking to my kids.
It happens when I'm talking to someone
who knows the technical language that I
don't know.
So I got interested in how it translation
can also happen within the things that
we think of as, as being languages,
not just between them. Um,
but alongside that,
um,
there's quite a while it seems to me
quite a loose way of thinking that says,
well, everything is translation. Really.
All communication is translation.
You find people,
this is a donor if you come across this,
but this is the sort of
phrase that floats around.
And I don't like that phrase because
as soon as you expand a word enormously
like that, expand it metaphorically
like that, it loses all or meaning.
But I found that I was interested
in, you know, um, I've,
I was nevertheless though,
um,
I was interested in the
idea that translation can
happen within a language as
well as between it.
Um,
so those really are the two or the other
to sort of overarching questions that I
bring with me to the topic.
One is everyone thinks that poetry is
lost in translation and yet my experiences
that you can create poetry
through translation. Um,
the other one is I don't really like the
phrase or communication and translation
because I feel it's meaningless.
Nevertheless,
I'm really interested in the idea that
translation happens within a language,
you know,
between different kinds of the same
language as well as between different
languages. Um, okay. So what I'm
going to, uh, yeah, so that's, that's,
that's sort of a, that that's
kind of where I'm coming from now.
What I want to do now.
I've had a little drink.
He's just though cause some instances
of things that some as it were,
scenes of translation,
uh,
from different moments and different
cultural places and different moments in
history just to get a sense of the
variety of the field as it were.
Um,
so the first one is the school classroom.
And this is where I learned my language
is, and maybe this is a kind of familiar,
a familiar environment to many of you.
So in a classroom or you're in an exam
hall as here and there's a passage of a
foreign language on the whiteboard or
on the blackboard or on the text and you
have to translate it and your translation
is going to be marked by the teacher
or the examiner. Um, so you're going to
get ticks and crosses and you'll get,
you'll get a mark as a result of that.
So what's happening in this instance of
translation or this scene of translation
is firstly it's subject to discipline.
Um,
and I think as soon as you're using the
word translation questions of right and
wrong or better and worse kind
of come into the room as well.
So the idea of translation, the idea
of discipline kind of belong together.
The other general point I want to bring
from this particular context is that the
kind of translation that school kids or
students do in order to show that they
know the language is a very,
is a particular kind of thing.
So the teacher is marking it
and the teacher is saying,
can I tell from this translation that the
student has understood the text in the
original language?
Well enough.
And so in that environment you're doing
something that's called translation,
but what's controlling what you actually
do is the need to show the teacher that
you're understood the foreign language.
And that means that lots of kind of
freedom that say literary translators,
translators of novels or translator,
he's just somebody speaking in somebody
else's speaking to interpret orally. Um,
that the kinds of of of,
uh,
thing that in those circumstances you're
able to do in a school or university
setting,
you are not able to do because you're
subject to this discipline of showing that
you've understood this grammatical form
and this phrase and this idiom and so on.
And that's why the kinds of translations
that get done in school context,
we'll get done in academic contexts often,
you know, read and quite a stilted way.
Um, because they're not
being designed to be read.
They're being designed for this
particular, um, academic exercise.
So the general points I wanted to get
from that are there translations and we're
just into our language. Um, it's
being done in a particular context,
subject to a set of particular
expectations for a particular purpose.
Um,
so,
and those were always things when you're
thinking about what's going on in any
instance of translation,
those are always things that are going to,
or that you need to bear in mind.
I want to briefly to contrast this
with a much kind of freer, um, or,
or kind of multilingual, um, kind
of context moving across languages.
So say you've got a group of,
I mean as I guess happens in
this building quite a lot.
Let's say you've got a
group of people speaking,
they all know different languages.
You want to communicate, um,
you want to find a shared
medium of communication.
Maybe English is the shared language,
but the people speaking are coming
from different languages into English
speaking English or speaking
English in slightly different ways.
And you sort of negotiate a medium
of understanding, don't you?
So say there's an Italian speaker and
the Italian speaker might say to the
English,
speaking in Bocca Lupo in Bocca Lupo
is an Italian way of saying good luck.
Literally it means in
the mouth of the wolf.
Then your speaker might not understand.
The Italian speaker might explain,
the French speaker might say,
you know,
Marshalls or something
and you'd have a kind of,
on the one hand are kind
of coming to understand,
but on the other hand is sort of
freer area of language mixing,
which is quite different
from the classroom setting.
So that's showing how what happens across
languages can be quite different in a,
in a, in, in a different setting.
The other thing it's showing,
which I'm not sure how much
I'm going to talk about,
but maybe we can talk about in
discussion at the end. Um, yeah,
we'll talk about it.
And discussion at the end is the,
the real importance of the difference
between spoken language and how people
behave with their voices and written
language and how people move across
languages when they're dealing
with writing. Um, or on a
screen. And actually the,
the, the, you know,
the Internet was obviously blurring
that distinction to some extent. Um,
but I'm just going to leave that there
for the moment. Um, and come back to it.
Now. My next example is from
back in the 16th century.
Um, and who we have here is the sultan.
Um, the Ottoman sultan in Constantinople
Sultan Murad the third. Um,
and we have Queen Elizabeth
the first of England. Um,
and they're writing letters to each other
or they're in diplomatic communication.
Um, and um, the way that works is that,
um, no one really in the Turkish court
understands English and no one really in
English court understands Turkish.
So they use Italian as
an intermediary language.
And obviously both these rulers are
tremendously proud and you know,
each one has a very,
as a very vivid sense of her own
importance or his own importance,
but they need to negotiate in the way
they communicate to one another in such a
way as to, uh, you know,
not spark a conflict or,
or not fall out too much.
And so the person who's charged with this
is the translator person who's charged,
not only with putting the meaning
across from one person to another,
but also sustaining a peaceful channel
of communication is the translator and
the Turkish word for this kind
of translation struggle, man. Um,
and there's a lovely bit in one of their,
um,
and one of their letters where
the sultan writes, you know,
Elizabeth has written a letter to,
to south and the third,
and he writes back saying,
thank you Monique for demonstrating
your subservience and devotion to me.
Um, and I've, I've got, um, I've got
the, uh, my Turkish is not really good,
but his are, it will be deactivate the
last than that. I can't speak Turkish,
but those are the,
the um,
the Turkish words and the
dragon looks at that and things.
And Elizabeth the first is not really
going to be very pleased to see that he
thinks that she is subservient to him.
Uh,
so when he translates that
into Italian, he says, uh,
he changes it to thank you
for showing censhare Amie Gto.
Thank you for showing sincere
friendship. Um, towards me.
And when she receives the letter a,
that's what she understands.
And the same thing happens the other
way and you've got to think of how sweet
and how, you know, how unusual.
But actually, um, this,
uh,
so what we have here is an instance of
translation and diplomacy going together.
And the point I want to draw from this
is that translation is also always a
matter of doing something that's going
to be acceptable in the community that
you're moving the text into. So
when you're wondering, okay, um,
here's the thing, this other language,
I'm writing it in this language,
I'm going to translate it into this
language, but I need it to be readable.
I need people to accept it. Um,
I need people, yeah, I need,
I need it.
I need to put it into language in a way
that is going to be acceptable in the
community I'm putting
it into language for.
So the general point I want to
take from this, uh, Elizabeth,
the first and salt and Morehead instances
that translation's always got an
element of diplomacy in it
is not just about, again,
it's not just about moving from
one language to another language.
It's about recognizing the,
uh,
language is a medium of
communication for a culture,
for a community. And uh, thinking about
entering into that community as well.
My last instance, um, is from a
long time earlier. So it's from, um,
the very first years of what we
call the common area in China. Um,
and the situation here is the um,
uh,
Buddhist holy people,
but his monks who knew the Buddhist,
we're moving from India to China,
just walking.
Um,
and they knew that bit of suture
is by heart in a language,
perhaps in Sanskrit,
perhaps in one of various other languages.
And they are arriving in China where
people are speaking kind of varieties of
Chinese and they want the holy
techs to be translated into Chinese.
And how did this happen?
Um,
the way this happened was that the holy
person he'd traveled from India would
knew the takes stop by home,
would recite it
in front of a whole group of people in
front of the BN assembly of Chinese holy
people.
And they'd listen and they'd consider an
they'd agree together what they thought.
The best translation of this,
these words in Sanskrit or other possible
languages would be made agree that,
and then somebody else would do the thing
of, of writing it down into a format.
There's, this isn't actually a
tax from, it's a Chinese suture,
but it's not actually a text
from, from um, all that time ago.
It's just kind of serving
as an, as an illustration of
this, um, this environment.
Um, so you look at that
and you think, okay,
this is surprising because
translation here is,
is being done by a group of people.
Whereas I tend to think of translation
being quite solitary activity like this
that takes over there. And I want to
translate it into this language over here
and here. We've got a group of people
agreeing how to do the translation.
And actually though when you,
um,
this phenomenon of crowd translation
is much more widespread than it first
appears.
Um,
so it's very obvious these days and crowd
translation services on the Internet.
So there'll be a translation company
and you send your tech stack to be
translated and two or three
people work on it or more. Um,
it's there in the way
Google translate minds,
lots of different tax in order to
find the translations that are um, up.
But actually they are all the way through
the history of translation as well.
So if you think about
the King James Bible,
so this is the great translation of the
Bible into English that becomes the core
tax to the Anglican Church,
uh, back in 1611. Um,
and that was done by 47 translators,
um, all working together.
And the reason for that isn't just that
it was a great long tax and they just
want it to do a bit each.
The reason for that is that they
needed to agree as a community.
And this relates to the diplomacy
point from a moment ago.
They needed to agree as a community,
what together they thought the right
translation of this holy text should be.
And you can see actually how,
you know,
especially with religious takes where
the whole point of a religious text is to
be a tax that sort of is shared among
a community that a community can enter
into and all agree about, um,
that this feeling of, okay,
we're going to agree on the translation
together, um, is going to be important.
And actually another thing that King James
Bible did was draw on lots of earlier
Bible translation. So, so much
a composite kind of taxed.
So that's another kind of
big and obvious example. But
actually if you think about
what any translator does.
So another example is Dryden, who's a, a,
a great English poet and
translator from the late,
from the 17th century or
pope from the 18th century.
These are people who are translating
from the classic striding is translating.
Virgil poke is translating homer.
Um,
but they weren't just working from
one lash text, the one Greek text.
So pope had quite good
Greek. It's, you know,
but he was also homer.
He was reading homer in a Latin edition
that had Latin notes and commentary.
He was aware of a French translation,
whereas was wherever an Italian
translation, he was using dictionaries.
So his translation enterprise
in fact wasn't just,
there's one text in that language,
and I'm putting it into my language is
much more a matter of drawing from many
different texts and drawing from many
different languages. And in fact,
if you think about,
you know,
even if somebody says something to me
in a language and I translate it into
English, what am I using in
order to do that? You know,
I'm using all the instances of people
speaking or the stuff I've read that my
language, you know, my knowledge of
language has come from in the first place.
So the point I want to take from that
then is the really ought, well, yeah,
all translation is crowd translation or
translation is always drawing on many
texts and negotiating between many texts,
not just taking one and turning it
into another one. So here my, Oh yeah.
So these are actually, um, these are
the King James Bible translators.
So all these people offering
up the Bible too, uh,
to King James. So that's the crowd of
those translations. So here are my,
here are my points that I've met so far.
Okay.
Now. Okay. So I'm just going to,
yeah,
it was for a moment. What's next?
Okay, I'll put that up there.
Okay.
So what I've hoped to do
with these instances, um,
is just flesh out a bit.
The variety and the complexity of the
kinds of doing things with language that
get called translation.
There's always a question of
discipline of right and wrong.
When translation is in the room,
you always need to think, okay,
what particular purpose and
context is it being done for?
It's not just a language,
it's got this diplomacy aspect because
it's about bringing a text into a
community and it's got this
crowd translation aspect
because you always know the
languages that you know from many sources.
So just want,
I just wanted to kind of
sort of add those perspectives.
Right.
Well, I want to do now is, okay,
just seeing how long I've been going for.
What I want to do now is think about the
relation between these kinds of ways of
moving across languages that we call
translation and languages. You know,
because as soon as you got translation,
you have to have languages.
Or at least that's the standard idea.
What does translation do?
Translation takes meaning
from one language and puts
it into another language.
So in order for that to be possible,
they need to be separate languages.
But how secure is this idea
that languages are separate? Um,
Derrida has an argument about
the word Bible. Um, and it's in
an essay called, uh, they taught about
bell, the towers or the turns of babble.
And he says, well, what language does
the Word Bible belonged to? You know,
it's a word in French,
it's a word in English,
it's the word in many other languages as
well. So if I write the word, you know,
you see a piece of paper like that with
Word Bible in it. What language is it?
And we don't know what languages.
And so if that word is shared between
languages that shows that the languages
aren't completely separate,
I think that he could have made the
same point about many, many words.
So this is just a paragraph from my
little boat that you've got and obviously
I'm writing it in English.
I was writing it and then I thought,
now many of the words that I'm using
are almost identical to words in French.
Um, and they, they are. So
I write the word identical.
It's almost like the words you don't
tick or right. The word paragraph.
It's just like the word park off.
I wrote the word pronunciation.
It's almost like the word panels.
Yes.
So lots and lots of words in English.
I'll almost identically shared with French
or Spanish or Italian and other sets
of English words that are almost
identical. He shared with German.
So there's lots of intermingling and
overlap between these languages that we
think of as being separate languages.
And it's the same with grammatical forms,
you know, grammatical form
that goes subject verb, object.
I like the cart Jim to show. It's the
same in across English and French.
And other languages. And then as you move
into languages that are further away,
it all gets, it gets more different.
So translation operates between,
um, how language is related to one
another is a very varied thing.
So you can have languages that are very
far apart like English and Japanese. So,
and you can have Englishes
that are very close.
So what we're dealing with in fat is a
whole landscape of language variation and
intermingling and overlap.
And what it is to translate from
a distant language, you know, to,
to the language that is distant from is
quite a different challenge from what it
is to translate between two very close
languages like English and French.
Um, now why though do we think
of English and French is being,
you know,
English is very varied.
There are lots of different
dialectal forms of English, you know,
groups of people speak English in
different ways or different technical
languages. There's lots of variation
within the thing we call English.
So why do we think of English and
French as being different languages?
And we think of English and French is
being different languages because they're
attached to different
political states basically. Um,
so what, how, what has happened
over the course of history? Um,
what really started happening,
uh,
in the 17th and 18th centuries is that
France and England saying started to say,
um,
we need to standardize our language.
Okay. English is being used
in many different ways.
Words have being spelled
in many different ways,
but now printing enters into this as well.
So printing over the last 200 years,
as soon as you've got printed books,
so famously Shakespeare,
every time he wrote his name,
spelled it slightly differently. Um,
and when you're in a manuscript
culture, that's, that's fine.
You can spell words differently.
It's all handwriting.
There's a lot of variety there.
But as soon as you move into
a culture of printed books,
the idea that spelling
variation is a problem in it,
spending variation starts
to seem like a problem. Um,
and what happens then is that people
create dictionaries and people create
grammar books saying this is the
correct way of spelling the word,
the correct way of spelling.
The word pronunciation in English has
got a u in it and it's different from the
way of spelling pronunciation and French
ones yesterday one which has got an o
in it.
Um,
so it's only as a result of that state
sponsored process of language regulation
that we think of English as
being a language over here.
And French is being a language over there.
And American is quite an
interesting example of this.
So there was a dictionary maker,
um,
in the United States in the early 18th
century who wanted American English to be
different from English,
English, Noah Webster.
And so the early additions of Webster's
American dictionaries and systematically
he chooses to spell words differently
from the standard English spelling in
order to try to make American English
seem, uh, different from English, English.
So what we've got here is, um, a,
a kind of enterprise of, um, language.
As soon as you've got a process
of language standardization,
this is the correct way of using the
language that separates it from other
languages.
And translation enters into that because
it's only when you've got a language
that separate or a kind of way of using
language that feels different that you
need to translate in order to
get into this language over here.
And you can see that the sensitivity
is around that. Say for instance,
they'll be film set in north of England
where people are speaking English with
uh, kind of, uh, you know, say a livable
acts and unembarrassed dialects are ways.
And then they get,
you know,
they show in America and they
have subtitles or sometimes
they show in the south
of England they have
subtitles. And then that's, um,
people get upset about
that because it's saying,
what do you mean this
isn't the same language?
So as soon as you translate by
putting subtitles there, you say,
this is something you can't understand.
This is something different from us.
Um,
another instance of this is from a
pilot in the 19th century called William
Bonds. We lived in Dorset
and he loved Dorset dialect.
And so he wrote his
poems in Dorset dialect,
which was a bit different
from standard English,
but he wanted Dorset dialect
of figure as a language.
He didn't want it to seem like just
the kind of minor variety of English.
And part of what he did in order to assert
this was translate his Dorset dialect
poems. I mean you can read the Dorset
dialect poems and understand them,
but he translated them into standard
English. And by doing that he said, look,
Dorset dialect is,
or language and English is another
language so I can translate between them.
So we've got this peculiar
phenomenon that translation creates,
enters into the creation of the separation
between languages, which then bridges.
Um,
here's a really striking,
very recent instance of this.
This is the Dayton accord from 1995,
which was the international treaty,
the establish peace after the,
um, the, the war in the former Yugoslavia.
So this established Croatia,
Bosnia and Serbia,
a separate national entities.
And because it was an
international treaty,
it had to be written in different language
versions for the different states.
Because the conventions of
international treaties is, you know,
if it's written in English and French
and English version and you have a French
version.
So in order to create this treaty that
needed to be a Croatian version of
Serbian version and a positive version,
well the trouble was these languages are
very close and overlapping and indeed
they hadn't been through that process
of standardization and separation that I
was just talking about in
relation to English. Um,
and here's one of the translators that
are talking about talking about what
happened politically. She
says, look, this is a,
one of the translations
Vulcan called Louise ask you,
I'm just gonna read it out cause it's
quite striking testimony I think.
So she's working for the multinational
stabilization force and she says our
language policy like that,
all the international organizations in
Bosnia fed into the devise of ethnic
politics in the country by providing
documentation and translations in three
very similar but different language
versions linguistically to members of the
various language services had a
hand in molding the three standards,
which is to say what counted as
creation and what counted is Serbian.
And what counted as positive because,
um,
it wasn't decided already
in linguistic circles.
What exactly constitutes the standard,
especially especially the Bosnian
standard, the various orthography is,
so that's books of spelling, dictionaries
and grammars who was an Indian.
Always agree.
So there was always much discussion in
this four edge Q language service on what
could actually be included in a Bosnian
version as against the Croatian or
Serbian. So here we've
got translators, you know,
establishing the separation of languages
in order to be able to translate
between them.
So this is translation as part of
an apparatus of language regulation,
which creates separations between usually
national languages and standardizes
languages within a nation state.
And then you get translation operating
between it.
The interesting thing though,
and this is um,
where we moved back towards the literary
phenomena that um, I said, you know,
interested me at the
beginning when I started,
is it translation can also mix languages,
um,
up and Google translate is quite good at
this actually. So the other day I got a,
um,
a spam email in German and I said,
I put this into Google translate
and it came out as in Germany alone,
there are around 25 million science
helped to make the road and to make,
say for all road users and say that's
not idiomatic standard English. That's,
you can see the Germanic, the German
forms of Sumach and kind of coming,
coming through in the way
the words are put together.
Now people often kind of smile at this
sort of thing and they point to that and
they say that shows that Google translate
isn't working as well as it should be.
You know, they call that kind of language
translation needs. They say, okay,
this is unsuccessful translation because
it hasn't achieved fluency in idiomatic
standard English.
But the peculiar thing is those kinds of
literary creativity that I was talking
about at the beginning,
the interested me right to the beginning,
often do very much the same
thing. Um, and I'm just gonna um,
show you some couple of instances of this.
I'm getting towards the end.
Um, so this is, this is Dryden.
The payer I mentioned a moment ago.
So He's through the 60 nineties
he's translating Virgil's Aeneid,
that great,
great poem.
And this is just the first line on
Marty widow and queer cannot throw a
equipping them with [inaudible] and so on.
And the way he translates it arms and
the man icing who forced by fate left the
Trojan shore. And you can see
how, how the words are lining up.
And actually the way he uses the word,
who there, you know, what do you mean?
Who goes with man arms? And the
man who forced by fate, it's not,
wasn't back then either a natural way of
arranging the English words and actual
of arranging the English words would be
icing of arms and the man who was forced
by fade.
So what he's doing then is he's taking
the Latin way with language and bringing
it into English.
And this way of moving what reversing
words and moving them around is something
that is common to do in English,
poetry of that time.
But it's common to do an English
poetry at that time because many,
many people writing it knew Latin very
well. And had Latin in their minds.
And so you've got this strange phenomenon
that what he's doing in order to write
a poem in English is borrowing
from lush and at word order and,
and Latin at way with language.
So he's mixing the kind of thing that,
exactly the same kind of thing that
we've got there. That in that context,
do you think, oh, that's Google
translate or working properly.
But as soon as you're in a
literary context where it's
okay to mess around with
language, I think actually,
you know, you know,
the general point here is that that
relationship between what we think of as a
mistake in ordinary language use and
what we think of as something interesting
as soon as it's in a poem or in a
literary text is quite, you know,
it's very close. Um,
here's another instance.
This is from the early 20th
century and this is Ezra pound.
Um,
and he's interested in finding ways of
writing poetry that don't have regular
rhythm and that don't rhyme.
And one of the things that helped him
to do this was an encounter with ancient
Chinese poems.
And he didn't understand Chinese,
but he was given the gift
of notebooks from, uh,
a Chinese scholar that looked like this.
So you get the Chinese characters,
you get English words underneath,
and you get a kind of commentary.
And he thought, okay, I can take,
I can see here that there's a way of
doing things with words as different from
the usual way of doing
things with words in English.
And I'm going to try to
write poems like this. Um,
and here's the beginning of one
of them, uh, which begins blue.
Blue is the grass about the river and
the willows have overfilled the close
garden.
And so what's unusual about this or what's
different about this for many poetry
that had been written before is,
um,
well not any poetry that, but what's
unusual about it is that it's not rhyming.
It doesn't have a regular rhythm.
And instead you've got this sort
of sequence of word units, blue,
blue grass,
river willows,
overfilled close garden.
And he's arranging his words like that
in imitation of what he understands of
the sequence of Chinese characters in
the Chinese poems that he's been looking
at. You know, and there's also the
strangeness of saying the grass is blue.
You know, what's the boundary between
blue and green is the evening. Um,
and there's also the title,
you know, the beautiful toilet.
I think that's meant to be
a slightly surprising title.
And what it means is, uh,
you know, getting, um, doing makeup and
things like that. It's not actually,
it's not actually a Lou. Um, just one
more instance of this very recent one.
Um, and then I stop. Oh No.
Then I'll kind of wrap up. Um,
this is from a writer.
I don't know if any of you been
reading called WG Sebald who is, um,
a writer who's been hugely successful in
English culture over the last 10 or 15
years. Um, he's somebody who lived
in East Anglia, um, he's German,
writes in German,
but it's very beautifully translated
into English by a couple of translators.
Michael Wholesale and bell.
He translated this one.
Now the kinds of novels that he writes
are quite like memoir, autobiography. Um,
so they're very located in a place,
but they are also a lot about feeling
out of place and a peculiarity about his
work is that,
say he's writing in German,
he was published in Germany and then he's,
you know which culture they do.
These books belong in. So
then his translation, the
books are written in English,
published in Germany,
translated into English,
published here and actually lots of
the reviews and celebration of WG.
Well in English literary press you
wouldn't know that he wasn't writing in
English. They just say, okay,
this is an amazing literary
style that he has an English.
And the interesting thing
about this is that this style,
again like the other instances we've
looked at came into being through
translation.
If you just look at this first sentence
and the second half of the 1960s I
traveled repeatedly from England to
Belgium, partly for study purposes,
partly for other reasons which
were never entirely clear to me.
Staying sometimes for just one or two
days, sometimes for several weeks.
So it's quite a sort of decorous
and formal and long sentence.
And generally that's
the case with his style.
But it's also just ever
so slightly different from
what you expect an idiomatic
standard English. I think if
you look at the phrase, um,
for study purposes and there's a German
phrase behind that as a studio in Spec,
but in English you'd say,
I'm,
I traveled repeatedly from England
to Belgium to study, you know,
and you apply for a visa for
study purposes. You know,
it's slightly unusual to
say I traveled to England,
to Belgium for study purposes. And so
what's happening here is that, you know,
again,
it's a very similar phenomenon to,
to make the road and to
make so for road users, um,
you've got a Germanic phrase
coming through into English,
but becoming part of a literary style and
what's cause you want a literary style
to be slightly unusual. You won a
literary style to kind of be distinctive.
And so what's distinctive about this
literary style is that it's slightly at
odds with standard English.
And that becomes part of the
imaginative world of the books,
which is so much about feeling
displaced from, um, from where you are.
Okay. Now the question, um,
I want to end up with
really is the, um, okay. So,
so here we've got two movements.
We've got a movement of
translation operating between
one standard language like
in the Croatian and Serbian creating
standard national languages,
wanting to translate from one standardized
language into another standardized
language. And there's a desire to do
that correctly and achieve fluency.
And on the other hand,
there's this creative use of translation
which changes the language. And in fact,
translation always changes the language
that it's, um, that it's being done into.
But usually when that becomes visible as
in the email version, people think, oh,
that's a mistake or that's a
failure to achieve fluency.
But when you're in a more literary realm,
that kind of strangeness is something
that People Are, can, you know,
people can get interested
in. Um, and enjoy. Now,
I just want to bring this into
context into, into contact with, um,
the way the world of communication.
Um,
it's changing because of the Internet
and also because of machine translation
programs like Google translate.
So that I think a lot of the rhetoric
around Google translate and similar
programs is the aim to achieve
fluency in a standard language.
Um,
and one of the things that the internet
does is spreads dominant languages like
English around the world.
But another thing the internet does
is it makes visible lots of varied and
dialectal and idiosyncratic,
a nonstandard uses of language.
So in social media and,
and you know,
also all sorts of kind of greets people
are coming out with language that's,
you know,
distinctive just belongs to that group.
It's misspelled according to the
standard expectations of spelling.
It's dialectal.
Um,
it's a mixture of English and French or
it's a mixture of different languages.
So I think there are two,
two sort of movements in what the
Internet is making visible or is doing
linguistically.
On the one hand,
there's the idea of a desire to achieve,
you know,
fluency and translation software.
But on the other hand,
there's the making visible of lots
of linguistic phenomena that kind of
challenge that.
Um,
and uh, yeah, so I think, um,
so I think there's a, there's a,
there's a question then, um, about,
about which version of translation,
um,
which what's sort of language use,
I mean obviously that they're both
going to carry on being there,
but how they relate to one
another and how they get handled,
which is to say does the creative kind
of translation which relishes difference
and strangeness and can be about me
manifesting my particularity as an
individual and achieving a particular
kind of mode of understanding with you as
an individual.
So that's about people playing with
language or people doing inventive things
with language,
which is part of what we do with language.
And on the other hand
as language regulation,
this is the sort of need
for clear communication and
business contexts or legal
contexts. Um, I, one of the
things I'm interested in,
I have no idea how people
use Google translate,
but the sort of assumption that things
like that, that email our mistakes,
we just need to move beyond and we need
to achieve in I clear communication
between different standard languages
that it seems to me that's very much the
rhetoric around her. But on the
other hand, I quite like, you know,
that the Kuli or versions of language
that Google translate producers sometimes,
and I like the sort of, you
know, there is different, um,
translation possibilities that it
opens up. So it seems to me this,
there was sort of different possibilities
for how translation is going to
feature on the Internet, um, in, in
the future, a more regulated version.
And as it were, a more inventive and
an archaic version. So I said, well,
what the future is, is obviously
going to be a world of translation,
but what kind of translation that is
going to be remains to be discovered.
Thank you.
Thank you for your attention.
[inaudible]
thank you very much.
We do have time for questions.
Yup.
Actually, I have a zillion
questions, but, um, I,
it seems to me that translation,
um,
is really important to the evolution of
language because a part of culture that
is, um, kind of carried
on to other nations,
whether geographically or otherwise.
Yeah.
And machine learning and Google
translate today is not capable of kind of
grasping those nuances that
come with, um, you know,
translation as we see it today.
Kind of understanding what the purpose
of the other is saying and trying to
translate it into not like semantically
the right kind of a flow with the words,
but kind of like what you mean like the
in Boca Lupo versus punching hospices.
But, so I was wondering your opinion,
what was your opinion on, um,
Esperanto and that regards?
Okay. Um, uh, what I
think about is Pronto is,
I don't know much,
I don't know much about us.
Brand test is just kind of
off the top of my head. Um,
so what I imagined about Esperanto is the,
I think the thing to ask about language
use is that it's, um, it's always, um,
there's a community doing
it. Um, so, um, the,
you know,
how subtle a language is,
how complex the communicative
interaction can be. Um,
all arises from what the
community's like this using it,
how long they've been using it and so
on. And I don't really, do you speak at,
do do you use US brand tone?
Not at all. I'm just wondering if it's,
yeah. If a solution, yeah. Anything.
No, I don't, I don't think those kinds
of things are, um, uh, solutions. I'll,
I'll say why in a moment. But, um, my,
my imagining about his brand too is,
so this is, uh, kind of
constructed language.
How much of a history does
it have or who's using it?
And so it's a language that you use
and then what's the consideration when
you're using it?
Is the consideration,
am I speaking Esperanto correctly
or is the consideration,
can I play around with us?
Bronto and indeed, I mean,
I don't know if you've
had these, you know, the,
the common experience of sharing a lang,
you know,
communicating with someone who speaks
another language and doesn't speak English
very well and you don't speak the
other language very well. And in fact,
what you do is you mix up the languages,
you sort of achieve a kind of local,
private Esperanto. Really. Um,
and so I think the question for,
um,
I think so Esperanto dates from in
the city before the Internet from,
from, from a hundred years ago,
whenever it was. Um, and I,
you know, it's just a question of
sort of what, what kind of usage, um,
it enables really, but the
reason why I don't think, um,
standardized international languages,
uh,
our solution is the language
is really got to two purposes.
One purpose of, of languages
to communicate with everybody.
But another purpose of language is to
say I, me and this group, you know,
speaking a language that's different
from that other language, you know,
where my teenage kids, you know, use
words, I don't understand. If they don't,
they don't do it because you know,
randomly they do it so that I
don't understand them, you know?
So it's about manifesting your identity.
So there's a,
so I think rather than saying
[inaudible] this. Okay.
And then this is the issue about the
spread of English as a global language.
On a technocratic spread of
English as a global language.
What should we think about that?
I think one thing to think
about that is that in, um,
defined technical or say business
contexts, you know, that's fine.
I think I said, okay, but what
about English as, um, you know,
just the medium that people are using to
communicate. I think I said, well, okay,
but what's going to happen
there? And this is all, you know,
this is obvious in the different kinds
of Englishes that there are around the
world. People are going to
be using English differently.
They're going to be playing with it.
They're going to be mixing your top,
they're going to be in. So
actually, and this is, I mean,
this is really one of the,
this is the, I think, I think the
big question, which is to say that,
um, before the Internet, um,
so actually, um, what I've been
saying is quite Eurocentric.
So what I have been saying is quite,
you're essentially so far, but so,
so before the Internet, if you think
about how print culture worked,
the market for printed books
was the night, you know, you'd,
you'd publish a book and it would be
in England or in America or in France.
So you had these national cultures.
It was all sorts of language variety in
the way people spoke from related to one
another and the word dialect or
groupings and HB things and so on,
said lots and lots of language for it.
But I didn't become visible in print and
it couldn't be shared and therefore it
couldn't be shared nationally.
You'd go to a village in the country and
they would use language in a particular
way, but that didn't spread, that
wasn't visible anywhere else.
And so in order to be widely read,
you had to go into this,
you had to produce a standardized
printed text in standard English.
Well the Internet makes visible is lots
of all the variety of languages that
previously wasn't visible.
It was just in,
in spoken communities is
now visible on Internet.
And I think how people negotiate that is
going to be really interesting to see.
And I'm interested actually with machine
translation software that, you know,
the degree to which the
ambition is continues to be,
let's move from one standard language
to another standard language will the
degree to which it can say,
you know,
this is your way of using language
in that community of a few speakers.
Let's mediate between this way of
using language, how it can, you know,
the degree to which you can kind of
register and cope with all the language
variety though is becoming visible.
Yeah.
Press one.
Hello Em.
So Google translate is not aiming to
make it possible for everyone to use
English. Yeah. The opposite. Yeah.
But do you think it will be a full
similar to printing and dictionaries in
helping to maintain a standard?
I think, yeah. I think, um, yeah,
I think it could go either way.
I think it's, I think it's just, I
think that's about how people, I mean,
I think it's partly about,
you know,
obviously I feel upset and trying to say
to think about it in this room, but, um,
it's partly about how it's constructed,
which I don't understand and
how it's going to, you know,
the future of how it's going to be
constructed. Um, but it's also about how,
you know, how people use it. Um, and so,
um, yeah, so I, you know, I can,
I can imagine a developing
in a way that allows,
you know that Sam's an idiosyncratic
nonstop, you know, that becomes inventive,
that allows somebody to,
you know,
put into it and inventive use of
language and English and for it then to
generate various possible,
different inventive equivalents
in different Italian,
many different Italian
dialects. Say, you know,
I don't see why I don't know
anything about technology,
but I don't see why it shouldn't
develop in that direction.
So I think one can imagine
it developing in a way that,
um, okay. So, so you think about,
okay, we need to communicate.
And one way of community,
one way of communicating is
being tolerant of diversity.
One way of communicating is you saying
something and me being patient, uh,
you know, uh, learning the words that
you're using, the, I don't know, you know,
so we can have a room in which people
are all speaking quite differently,
but nevertheless they are accepting of
their difference and they've got patients
to understand the particularities
of each other's languages.
And the other thing is, okay, no, we
all need to speak standard English,
so let's have a regulated environment
and that's take our individuality and
discipline it according to the Shad
codafide standard that we're all using.
Um, so all language use is partly
a matter of recognizing difference.
And it's all partly a matter of
establishing a common code. Um,
and I think how, you know, I think how
Google translate develops is going to be,
you know, I don't know
which way it will go. Um,
but I really hope it goes on the more
diversity way, but you know, in the,
in the lats rather than let's only
work between standard languages with a
communicative purpose in order to achieve
something that counts as fluency and
correctness. And rather than doing
that, if it develops in such a way,
as I was saying a moment
ago, that it's, you know,
that you can use it playfully and user,
you know,
enjoy the peculiarities of language,
all kinds of different language difference
that it makes visible to you then
that would be better I think.
Yep.
So I'm going to ask again
about the future of fashion.
Could it be different and go
into their actions? So, um,
automated versus the human part,
English versus Chinas.
So the first question would be what
things do you think that cannot be
automated?
100%.
You think there's going to be like a
human translator on side that is going to
steal their forever and the second side,
if we agree that Chinese is going
to be the next big language,
which bridges you think that are
difficult? Uh, in this, in this side,
we are in the Western world on the,
yeah, the first one. I don't see why
you said I'm very aware that, um,
whenever I do anything with language,
I'm mediating between languages and
words that have come into my mind.
You know, that's where I know my
language from. So I don't, you know,
I think there's a lot of romanticism that
says only human beings can do this and
machines will never be able to do this
because it seems to me that actually
I don't see why a machine
in the future shouldn't
have the same,
you know,
so that I think that at the moment what
a human being can do that a machine
can't do is, you know,
handle, you know, uh,
bear in mind a lot of
complexity and nuance and it,
that just seems to be a
matter of degree ready.
So I don't see why in the future machine,
I mean obviously I know nothing
about machines, but I don't see,
I don't see in principle why in the
future machines shouldn't develop exactly
the same kind of sensitivities as
it were that a human being does.
I think it's just romantic to to assume
that that's not going to be the case.
Um,
so for instance,
my enjoyment of those odd literary uses
of language that I was talking about a
moment ago that comes from my same work.
Okay.
The normal way of using English as this.
And there were various
unusual ways of using English,
this unusual way of using
English as a mistake.
And this other unusual way of using
English is actually quite interesting and
creative.
And why do I think that?
I don't think that because of some sort
of special spiritual humanity that I
have,
I think that because of,
I spend my whole time kind of weighing
different kinds of language use and being
aware of how words he is differently
in different contexts for different
purposes. So I don't see why
a machine shouldn't, you know,
develop that same kind of way of
handling language. But I mean,
obviously I'm, I don't know the
thing about how machines work. Um,
the thing about Chinese,
um,
I don't know Chinese and so I don't
really know what the issues are there, um,
particular what the particular
issues are there. Um, I think, uh,
yeah, so I don't, I can't
really sensibly answer that. Um,
I think one thing I think though is
the, um, the issue about, about script,
about forms of writing and
forms of speech, um, is,
is really interesting and that phenomenon
that there is in Chinese and related
languages like Japanese and Korean, that
they share lots of written characters.
I mean, um, I, I can't say how,
how similar and how different that is to
an English person being able to look at
a French text and being able to guess
many of the words because they're written
similarly. Um, but I think
that's an an, you know, that's
an interesting phenomenon,
but I can't, I can't talk seriously about
Chinese. I don't know anything about it.
Thank you for coming. Thank
you, Matthew Reynolds. Okay.
[inaudible].